hi I'm Erik Bosse in Star Wars Episode
nine the rise of Skywalker appears to be
betting heavily on beloved elements from
past films with its trailer ending with
the mysterious cackle of Emperor
Palpatine a title suggesting that the
Skywalker legacy will live on in some
new way and a while back remember a
leaked scene description featuring kylo
Ren witnessing Darth Vader's origin from
Revenge of the Sith is there too many of
them what are we going to do no not the
slaughter of the young liens the moment
the iconic Vader mask was placed on
Anakin's scarred and disfigured face and
he breathed Vader's signature breath for
the first time but this speculation of
Vader's possible return in episode 9
made me think about the best Vader
moments from Star Wars past and the more
I think about this while Darth Vader was
a perfectly chillin villain chillin
villain throughout the original trilogy
the one scene in which we saw his full
potential his true rage was in rogue one
the 2016 Star Wars story about the
rebels theft of the Death Star plans
previously enough to fill 18 words in
the original Star Wars opening crawl
wasn't perfect but it ended with a
heart-pounding chase between rebel
soldiers racing to hand off the Death
Star schematics as the deadliest Sith
slays them all one by one
let's rewatch this rogue one ending
moment by moment to analyze and
breakdown these specific reasons it is
the best Darth Vader sequence of these
Star Wars films okay so we're back in
the final minutes of rogue 1 gen or so
and her team has successfully
transmitted the Death Star plans to the
rebel Cruiser the profundity commanded
by Admiral Radice after the Battle of
scare off' opened up the shield gate the
Death Star arrived blasting the Imperial
base and everyone on the surface the
plans were still leaked Darth Vader
blocks the profundities escape to
hyperspace with his flagship the
Devastator invader boarded this rebel
ship to stop the data card from getting
away but before the rebel soldiers can
escape to their doctor the Tantive for
the hatch jams the lights in this tunnel
cut out the soldiers turn at the sound
of another hatch the opposite end
closing and then another sound under the
sounds of the sirens the breaths of
Darth Vader
the director of this film Gareth Edwards
focuses on these soldiers because
they're goofy helmets and faces a fear
perfectly matched the opening imagery of
the 1977 Star Wars directors telling us
that in these next few seconds we are
going to learn exactly what those
soldiers were afraid of and incite us he
creates the dread of dramatic irony
because we know from that 1977 opening
scene that none of these rebel soldiers
will survive and the point of view of
these soldiers returns later to the
mysterious space sorcerer that people
remove from the Skywalker saga CMS not
the complex tragic hero that we saw him
as in the prequels but now once again
the pure elemental evil that made us wet
ourselves as kids the darkness suddenly
illuminates red from the blade of
Vader's lightsaber now up until this
point
rogue 1 was the first Star Wars film not
to show a lightsaber because this story
was focused on the ground soldiers of
the Galactic Civil War not the Arthurian
Skywalker mythology of the rest of the
series but this red lightsaber severs
the final minutes of this film from that
war story drawing a line to mark the
transition back into the main Star Wars
narrative to remind us of the stakes of
this mission and the red lightsaber is
the primary source of light in this
scene the color red evokes emergency
lights the hell that Vader is now
trapped these rebel soldiers in and the
literal bloodbath of these casualties
now before rogue one we had obviously
seen Vader's violence on screen plenty
of times he choked rebels with his hands
he forced choked Admiral mati he engaged
Luke and obi-wan and epic lightsaber
duels
he used the force to block blaster bolts
and even gank blasters out of people's
hands and here in less than 60 seconds
Vader pulls off a highlight reel of all
of these past moves he effortlessly
swings his lightsaber as he did against
Luke and Empire he deflects blaster
bolts and force pulls blasters out of
hands like he did against Han Solo and
Cloud City he flees rebel bodies against
the walls and ceiling forced choking
them exactly as he did to Admiral mati
and bridging together all of these
visual callbacks is a raw ferocity from
Vader that was always under the mask
actually that first rebel that he forced
lifts to the ceiling Vader passes
to him with his fist still clenched
holding him up there but the clenched
fist also forms a menacing gesture to
the rebel over there at the hatch as if
to say how dare you try to defy the
Empire and without breaking eye contact
Vader flings his blade behind his back
slashing the lifted rebel meanwhile the
soldier with the data card desperately
reaches through the hatch opening with
Vader's saber framed behind him slashing
closer and closer the sequence is edited
with the claustrophobia of a horror film
here we see a screaming victim fleeing a
killer through an impossibly narrow gap
to freedom actually later when this
rebel does pass the card through the
second rebel trips just like every
fleeing horror film victim headed in Lee
does sure it's a cliche but it does make
sense because when you're that scared
you lose your balance you become a klutz
it's like when you have a nightmare and
you try to run in your dream it's really
difficult because your body in real life
is asleep so it's like you're paralyzed
so the rebel who hands off the data card
gets gored at the last second the saber
pierces the door and then the hatch
opens to let Vader through and that is
one of the two great hidden details of
this sequence the reason this hatch was
jammed the reason they couldn't pry it
open the reason all of those rebels were
trapped in that hallway for the
slaughter Vader was holding it closed
the whole time a long time now the other
great detail about the sequence is the
music rogue one was composed by Michael
Giacchino
who chose to be more discreet with his
references to John Williams classic
themes the music here is a dramatic
choral chant if you're familiar with the
composition of John Williams Star Wars
themes they're known for their brass
instruments carrying the melody like the
French horn of the forest theme the
trumpet of the main Star Wars theme one
memorable exception was Williams duel
the fates theme from The Phantom Menace
which of course used a chorus human
voices Williams did that to give the
duel a religious temple-like feel
chiquinho does a similar effect here
with Vader as a spiritual force bringing
him full circle with his first
appearance in the film in his Sith
temple also the chorus voices blend with
the screams of Terror from the rebel
soldiers as if each step of Vader's
Death March unleashes a shriek of agony
but most impressively the music still
feels familiar
and part of Vader's DNA because
chiquinho sneekly based it on John
Williams music if you speed it up you
can hear how it's actually the Imperial
March theme look at my opinion rogue one
was a much better film than people have
given it credit for and honestly the
last Star Wars film that made me jump to
my feet in the plaza the closing credits
and this Darth Vader sequence is exactly
why it restored the best villain of
Hollywood cinema to his iconic
silhouette and it allowed that shadow to
show off with the horror that made him
the ghost story of the Star Wars
universe comment down below with your
favorite Darth Vader moment and follow
me on instagram and twitter at EA boss
it subscribed a new rock stars for more
Star Wars analysis breakdowns for all
the updates for upcoming Star Wars
properties thank you for joining me and
yep wet myself
[Music]